So now we know how to start with personas and
use cases to always keep our end user in mind.
>> Yeah, it's really important to keep our
persona and use cases in mind, as designers
and developers when we're prioritizing feature lists, figuring
what to build, how to build it and when
to build it. Because if we don't do
that we fall into the trap of creating applications
either for no one or everyone, or just
for ourselves, both of which are really bad options.
>> I think we can really consider ourselves divine,
dev, design-minded developers at this point.
>> Yeah, exactly. So what's next in the process now that
we've talked about personas in each cases and prioritizing feature lists?
>> Well what we want to next is focus on next is low res wireframing.
We talked a little bit about that in lesson one, and we're going to go into
it more in lesson three. And lesson three
is going to be all about the mobile user,
because after all, we are building Android apps
and we need to start thinking mobile first.
>> Awesome.